at least 8,000 drug conviction
convictions in Massachusetts are likely
to be thrown out because of a state drug
lab scandal the state attorney general
joined public defenders and the ACLU in
pushing for the dismissals the tainted
cases are tied to former lab employee
Sonja ferric she admitted to using drugs
she was supposed to be testing Paula
Reed is here with the latest problems
tied to the Massachusetts drug lab Paula
good morning good morning if these cases
are thrown out many people will be
getting out of prison and it will be the
second time in two years that thousands
of drug convictions are being thrown out
for official misconduct in the state at
least eight thousand cases are now in
the hands of the Massachusetts Supreme
Judicial Court for eight years
Sonya farik worked at the Department of
Public Health Amherst Laboratory as a
chemist responsible for analyzing
samples in criminal drug cases in
January of 2013
authorities discovered unlabeled drugs
at Farex workstation
she was arrested after a search of her
car revealed even more stolen drugs
during her trial farik admitted to using
drugs in the lab and even manufacturing
in the lab of crack cocaine for her own
personal use she was given an 18-month
jail sentence this is a really a
historic case here in Massachusetts
Carole Rose is the executive director of
the Massachusetts ACLU the group is
seeking the dismissal of all the
convictions based in part on evidence
farik handled tens of thousands of
families who have been impacted by this
because their loved ones had served time
in jail and in prison this isn't the
first drug lab scandal in Massachusetts
in 2013 chemist Annie dookhan
who worked at a state lab in Boston pled
guilty to falsifying the result of drug
tests over an 8-year span in April the
Massachusetts Supreme Judicial Court
made the historic decision to dismiss
nearly 22,000 wrongful drug convictions
in cases that duquan worked on her
output was prodigious and frankly
unrealistic because she was just making
it up the magnitude of this disaster is
grand to say the least
Nicole d'abord is a former assistant
district attorney she says the cases
involving farik will likely be thrown
out and will be difficult to prosecute
again they're going to have to undo all
these cases
which will take more time than it
probably did to prosecute them in the
first place eleven of the states
District Attorney's believe some of the
cases are still pursue about the Amherst
drug lab where ferric work is now closed
the ACLU hopes a decision can come in
the early spring Paula thank you